e
good morning everybody um I'm going to
reconvene the committee of conference on
House Bill 1127 uh we did call for a
recess on Tuesday to get some legal
advice and legal opinions so I guess it
would be beneficial do start with
that did did you did is that the
attorney you were speaking to in if you
want to come up and uh give us your your
opinion I'll uh I'll I'll do my best
um the can I have you state just your
name my name's uh Richard Layman I'm the
legal council for the Senate thank you
the I starting sort of working starting
on section
nine um line 27 of the draft Amendment
appears to create a um anomaly where New
Hampshire DMV would issue a license to a
person um and permit that person to
drive in New Hampshire but the same
person of the same immigration status
who obtained a license in another state
like Massachusetts or anywhere else
would not have that recognized here so
um it seems like those two things don't
fit together uh in a way that um is
immediately rational the section seven
uh of the
amendment I think works to an extent
except that it excludes it excludes a
class of people um who are uh lawful but
not permanent residents like people with
student visas um and other non
non-permanent visas now I believe those
people could get a New Hampshire license
if they wanted to correct so you're not
excluding them entirely but it would it
would require that additional step
for out of state students on student
visas who come to New Hampshire which is
something that's been discussed in the
past anyway so I think that section
so that's interesting because section
nine with the ception of the words
notwithstanding I say 26 340a is current
law is it not uh but I believe it is the
but it works sort of hand and glove with
the section that's being notwithstand
comments um just briefly I I I think
that as um attorne lit has summed it up
it it's I I don't see this as being at
all workable um and certainly not at
this late hour to try to put in this
kind of an
amendment well if I'm not mistaken if I
hear you
correctly because of the change from um
lawful U lawfully present to lawful
permanent residency that creates the
anomaly uh that you're stating between
what's what we're allowing New Hampshire
uh residents to do versus out of state
no I don't think that is correct that's
um the the difference between lawfully
president and lawful permanent resident
is just
category uh of Whose license will be
recognized it's the um
anybody I guess what I'd suggest is that
if we want
to um move forward with the out ofst
state driver's license provision which
we attached to
127 um that we vetted and think it's
workable that that's probably at this
late date the best option for all of us
and I'm just looking I know that the
house rejected it but it
was uh seemed to be 176 to 174 so um I
but actually um compromise yes but
actually I was trying to make the the
bill do more uh because again like I
said and explained the difference
between lawful presence and being here
legally it's two different things so if
I'm hearing you correct you're not going
to support the amendment you would like
to see the original language of 358 move
hearing and I I um I'm not there and
here's why you just mentioned 176
174 um there's a definition of insanity
you know when you keep trying to do the
same thing over and over and expecting
different results uh for I was willing
to take another shot bringing this to
the floor with an amended language
because I'd have some to argue that it
actually does something uh but I'm not
willing to take this back to the floor
uh with the same language it makes no
sense to me so that's where I'm at with
it I would more at this point because I
am not dying on the sword for this uh
just for the public record I did put a
um what I thought closed loophole for
even people in New Hampshire uh that
would have matched what what section s
does and I think might have removed the
anomaly in section 99 but that bill was
um indefinitely not indefinitely
postponed but interm studyed in the
Senate that would be H Bill
1118 um so now we are at it bits and
pieces of something that's going to
accomplish nothing so I don't know if
you'd like to chat for a minute but
that's my position I'll even put it to a
motion uh if need be because again I'm
not falling in the sword for this and
I'm not bringing it to to the house
twice I'll make the motion that uh the
house succeed to the Senate position
upon further Amendment and that further
amendment is to remove all language
related to Senate Bill
358 is there a second for
you just and may I just ask a question
before so you're suggesting that we just
the only thing be included is the
original language of 1127
thank
you
e
okay um where are we at thank you Mr
chairman we would like to respectfully
ask for a recess to this afternoon um
we're going to see if we can try to
reconcile that particular language that
you are speaking of um and we just need
some time to do that so is it possible
to to do that um because we're
11:30
okay I think you could come back without
us okay okay I I can come back without
I know we're all
busy and I did bring a draft Amendment
here to try to expedite things we had
the conversation about some of the
issues that we had uh in possibly
creating the holes at our last meeting
and now you're asking to come back again
in another two and a half
hours let me Jack one minute so I think
that the purpose of that would be unless
we have a solution you agree to that
will AED to the house position okay
that's that's what we're that's what
do thank you um thank you Mr
chairman I understand that everybody's
trying to work toward Wards a a place
that
um works but there's there's these are
complicated difficult issues and it's
really worrisome if we're going to try
and fix them in a in a couple of hours
with with all new players and it's hard
for me to you know hard for me to see
that that's a a the way to go so let me
let me just repeat that if we can't get
something everybody agrees to we're
prepared to AED to the house position
and there would which the house position
is the base Bill 1127 so just just to
again clarify there won't be new people
sitting here they will be in a different
Committee of conference I will be here I
will have the authority to to say we're
going to aced to what you want but we
just want to get have an opportunity um
to see if we can really focus in on that
particular section and see if we can get
some sort of resolution okay fair enough
uh we can take a break till 11: I'll
confirm that this room is available but
at least we'll if not I'll find a
different room okay um but before we do
go through this motion um do you know I
have any
indication if whatever solution you're
coming up with is actually Germain to
358 because you know we operate under
some it has to be some rules we know
that okay all right well then 11 o' and
thank you Mr chair alternatively planned
for this room if it's not it we'll post
it somewhere what room it's in thank you
thank you again we'll be on break till
you
e
be
so once once we're settled down here I
there good morning good morning how are
you good morning I'm doing well so it
being uh 10:00 I'm going to open the uh
Committee of conference on House Bill
518 and welcome everybody thanks for
being here thanks for okay I know um GNA
let uh representative groda uh start out
because
she was uh I think chairing the
subcommittee work session that dealt
with uh some of these issues
so so on the side by side thank you um
representative leus on the if we look at
page starting on page 39 I
believe um the Senate added their
language to house Senate Bill
485 and Senate Bill 485 when it came to
us to the Edna committee was very
similar to a bill that we had heard
earlier House Bill 8
1385 so when we received Senate Bill
485 we took out the similar language is
between the two bills they were both
dealing with the fast tracking of
military individuals with license for
licensing and the the only two issues
that remained on Senate Bill
485 were the digitally verifiable
licenses and excuse me the
um the part of the bill that addressed
that and this is an important part that
was in the Senate bill but was not in
the house bills and we left it in the
Senate bill it had to do with those
licenses that are the uh under the
responsibility of boards that do not
report to
oplc and they should also have this fast
tracking mechanism and I believe the RSA
that's referred to is
327g um and that would we left that in
the Senate bill now I don't know I think
Senate bill at 485 the the the version
that we sent
back um was a
to for one reason or another I don't
remember but it didn't make it back to
the Senate and I don't know why I don't
remember I'm sorry so when you added
this language back in to this bill
because it's important you added the
Senate bill in its entirety as opposed
to the version that we had noodled out
the differences between the house bills
House Bill
1385 has gone through the Senate passed
the Senate and it's on the way to the
governor's office so that language
already exists as a statute so we we
just want to make sure that if we were
to
adopt the house amendment to Senate Bill
485 which really only deals with the
boards that are not under oplc having
the same FASTT tracking mechanism that's
advisable and then as far as the
digitally verifiable licensing we took
that out because when when commissioner
goule came to speak to us in the
committee of conference I mean in our
subcommittee he indicated that they
don't have the software or the mechanism
to do this now so it's not something
that we can um uh initiate but it is
something that they're looking
into um and the we had one during the
hearing we had one um individ ual
private individual testify that their
company could do that but we don't know
if that's the only company can do that
that can do it are there other people so
we chose to and they were promoting
their mechanism and their software so we
didn't
know how we should examine that in
relation to the fact that we don't have
that software and I just add one thing
that we got testimony on then that is I
think um the information on Whose
license is already online at op on the
oplc site so that is readily available
arguably digitally but not the technical
you know digitally verifiable
license uh r m py thank you Mr chair
thank you to letting me add in very
specifically uh commissioner GLE did
mention that there's a whole again like
we talked about whole transformation of
website access online access they are
making that a more uniform across all uh
offices and uh you know website looking
very similar so and access also so
that's in the process it's not ready
right now if you incorporate this it
would be how do you find that in the
weed so it's timeliness of putting that
digital
verification that could be something
that could once this
happens uh the
infrastructure is ready then that could
discussion my apologies I'm trying to
find
my excuse me I'm looking for that
Amendment on my for which for um to 45
45 I'm looking for the amendment number
so that we can it's I've got it here
it's 1610 I've got one copy okay so if
you could just kindly show it to um this
was the house amendment to 4 no words
it's I'm sorry what was the number of
the amendment uh 1610 1610 to 48 I had
45 16
10 and that's the one the committee
Amendment not the four amendment that
was added I don't see that on oh I'm on
the wrong one yeah I don't see that
Amendment on the general
1610 and if anybody needs it I I printed
so as I recall
from house our I'm I'm trying to recall
our hearing on how cill 485 yep which
was a very long time ago and I'm trying
to recall some of the information of it
would would you be opposed to Bringing
Mr oer up for no it's
fine uh Mr oser I can come over there I
have my I have it pulled up hang on a
second let me just come over
there uh so Mr Oar if you can come up
questions good morning Doug how oplc
okay if you have questions all right
thank you good morning see you again
I'm trying to go back and
um and recall here some of the testimony
on 485 and I don't have that in front of
me on the it you have um as I recall I
think director Courtney testified on 485
when we had this and we were discussing
the digital verified portion of that c
can you refresh my memory just a little
bit on that so I think the digitally
verifiable piece was a little fuzzy at
the beginning because as representative
leus has pointed out we do have a way to
verify lure on our website right now we
weren't sure if that me the definition
uh we were working with commissioner
goule to kind of see if this is any
different if this if it would require
other things and I think as
representative cotus said in working
with commissioner gulay he came out and
said this is going to be a long tedious
process it's going to cost a lot of
money and we're just not quite there yet
I think I think our expectation is that
within a few years this will probably be
a standard thing but now is not really
the time
okay um yes Senator thank you is there
um is there an interest or a proposal
being worked on in your office to
propose a budget item for next year to
do this or to evaluate some of these
software options that um repres
resentative groa was talking about so
that we could move towards this kind of
digital
verification so that's probably a
question better suited for director
Courtney um to the best of my knowledge
there is not okay but I can't say that
with 100% certainty um I also want to
point out that if something like this
were to be implemented it would probably
be a
doit project not necessarily an oplc
project we would work with the oit but
it would be on them and then the
finances we would have to work out but
but it would be doit who took the lead
clarification represent M yeah um if you
could clarify like I put it
infrastructure to verify doesn't exist
outside of oplc is the infrastructure it
infrastructure that's needed to verify
digitally is what the Department of it
is working on and with the website and
the software and once that is
ready oplc can do the digital am I
correct I think so but I think to answer
that fully I would have to speak for
doit which is not something I can do I
can say
um right there there are kind of two
pieces there's the website that we
maintain now where you can look up to
see if somebody's license if they've
been dis disciplined what happens
outside in the doit realm was a bit out
of my
perview okay so thank you so uh I mean
that's that's the reason why we removed
the digitally verifiable licensing part
of it um representative grot as I recall
uh the reason your Amendment also took
some other pieces out was because they
um they were in 1385 is that correct
it's correct correct they overlapped
with
1385 so there were two things that were
I'm remembering now cuz I'm reviewing my
notes from the subcommittee work on
485 and the amendment itself um a
definition of what digitally verifiable
licenses is is part of the issue because
there are many ways of digitally
verifying things the the um the process
Scott Withrow is the individual that's
that was the that spoke at our hearing
and his company
um has a process that is the ultimate in
digitally verifiable licensing and is
that what we want as a state and do we
want to invest in that as opposed to
what is what are our expect what are our
expectations of what digitally
verifiable licensing is and because
there's a whole plethora of software we
felt that and we didn't have any of it
we felt that we should pull that out
because one we can't do it and two we
need to figure out what it is that and
that's what we and that's why I know
director Courtney was going to work with
commissioner goule on trying to put some
be some definitions on that does that is
that what you recall I do recall that
and I somewhat alluded to it about I I
use the term fuzziness that was actually
what I was trying to say it was
articulated better so one question is is
there a St
for what a digitally verifiable license
is that exists outside of New Hampshire
I mean because somebody for it to be
digitally verifiable somebody else
presumably not New Hampshire is going to
want to make use of that but if there's
no standard that is generally recognize
what would that
mean that's an it question I don't
really have an answer for and we we
didn't get an answer to that uh you know
in
the in the public hearing or as far as I
know afterwards so
that was part of our concern we yeah
repr so Senator Pearl and and I guess
I'm speaking to the Senate is your
concern on the 485 portion of it the
inclusion of the de verifiable I'm
trying to figure out can we a do we
agree that this subcommittee work that
took Senate bill that took the
components of House Bill
1385 out of Senate bill
485 is no long is is is we're in
agreement there and that digitally
verifiable licenses is what we're trying
to Noodle out here well that's I think
we're getting there because you had very
different testimony than what we had on
yes that be the case uh we didn't we
didn't have any of this discussion and
so that's why we're trying to get up to
speed real quickly what you're you're
giving us information we didn't have
right okay so that's why I asked also
how come up and sure and I guess if I
may ask one more question certainly so
are you feeling like that the house
version of 1385 was 1385 right 1385 yeah
the house version of 1385 covered all of
the other components of Senate bille
485 without the digital portion I would
say yes so one thing we did because we
were working on these bills sort of in
tandem is when we finished the language
of
1385 uh director Courtney representative
Carol Brown and I believe
um Colonel
Perry we did a crosswalk Al together I
was involved behind the scenes too um we
did a crosswalk to make sure we weren't
missing anything and everyone was
satisfied that the components that we
were pulling out the one bill were
contained in
1385 that's a long-winded way of saying
yes I think we're satisfied outside of
the digitally verifiable piece so the
only portion of 485 that isn't in is the
digitally
verifiable yeah I I can see that written
we have written
got I see it's in here it is right here
in where is it
l this is the language but this but this
is the language that they put in into
here not withstanding any general
special LA to the country so part
two so this language we could get rid of
this because it's this is already going
this I pause excuse me I would to make
sure that the um the wording from
Amendment 1610 is added to Senate bill
to House Bill 1079 so that we make sure
518 518 we're dealing with 518 518 I'm
so sorry I got too many numbers in my
apologies let me start over I would
recommend that the amendment 1610 which
talks about um these um military
education me yeah that's portion of it
is what we add to Senate bill to House
Bill 1518 this part is very important
and was in Senate Bill 485 and was not
in 1385 so there this one small piece
exactly 485 as it came out of the house
right with the house Amendment so the
remainder of 485 sorry yeah no no please
the remainder of
485 is in 1385 except for the digitally
verified abortion I'm just trying to
make sure I that yes exactly exactly
between the two between the two adding
this amendment covers everything and we
still leave digital verification on the
table for next year to Define and fund
correct that the that that's the
motivation here correct that's our next
step is to figure out how to digitally
verify and move this and and close the
circle on this project I think for do
that we'd have to get together with
director right short that out yeah that
is not a today we that is not a thing we
okay
not so would it be your
proposal
that we use this amended language to add
to to take 518
without Senate Amendment and add that to
it and that's what we would do for now
and we have that yeah okay um I have a
side the or and matters appealed
pursuant to RSA 31014 until the office
has issued a final decision this is the
temporary licenses yes and this is fine
I don't believe this is an issue for us
we could in addition to six language and
1610 yeah add some of these other change
I looked at a number of them um the one
on page five was fine um there okay so
keeping in the temporary the the
temporary license so that people can
move forward while we're evaluating that
we can do that okay I'm fine with that
and also on page nine there's another
change which is just this section it's
sort of a language but I mean I don't
have a problem with that certainly check
that out and then on page 11 of the side
by side the first one is just a fix we
missed I think from board to office
yep and um changing the uh the the
notice requirement to instead of having
it in here uh refer to U you know the
RSA 5.8 I mean you're fine everybody's
fine with that we can leave yeah we can
leave that that's fine yeah I looked
through this there was a number there's
another one here on page
14 yeah actually that's when I had a
question about I
think um our language was they cannot
meet Quorum and the Senate changed a
last lack sufficient members to and I
have a guess as to what the motive was
behind that but I if you could
uh speak to that that's fine
page
14 I mean is that an issue that they
can't meet Quorum could be because for a
particular meeting they couldn't get
everybody there or enough people there
had a number we had a number of
uh conversations with a multitude of
boards who were struggling with um
getting Quorum and and there
was I don't know Senators if you can
refresh my memory there was some there
was some discussion about changing cor
to being 50% plus one in order to be
able to conduct business for a number of
boards this this could have been one I
don't I'm going to look at but this is a
more General I mean this is a more
General um I I guess um the Senate
version lacks sufficient members to for
them it really Narrows the parameter so
that the only reason that the ex itive
director could do this as if there's
lacking sufficient members rather than
any other reason why they couldn't I
don't know what that would be well I I
mean thinking about it myself I thought
of the situation for one particular
meeting they couldn't get enough people
to attend although there were enough
members who were appointed and confirmed
um and so that would let the director
executive director take over just
because one meeting they couldn't do it
and and yeah your version tightens it up
which I'm okay with
okay yeah okay yeah um just to clarify
so the Quorum requirement for each
meeting versus per meeting your Senate
version gives that leway to
say for each meeting versus quum
requirement for the entirety of the
board they just can't get so I mean
that's everything I think we're fine
with all the changes the Senate made up
to uh page 27 in the side by
side um right maybe the the Senate can
explain what the changes why they added
this to the disciplinary
portion and whether or not I'm I'm just
concerned because we wa what page you
page 27 because in 20 when we did House
Bill
655 and we we made a lot of changes to
the to the disciplinary action
overall and I just want to make sure
that this doesn't conflict with that or
what the what the um reasoning was
thinking about and maybe
um Mr ostow can help with that
because this is so those are the those
are the changes from page 27 in the side
38 I don't have a copy of that bill in
front of me is there anyone bill or this
can do you have a copy of the side by
at Doug if I remember correctly this was
the amendment that Senator Perkin cker
brought in if I'm not
mistaken yeah I didn't see it listed as
a separate amendment I didn't well I
think she did it in our committee
amended the bill in our committee okay
this is language she
changed that was part was part of a
larger Amendment maybe well I think it
part of the committee committe Amendment
okay part of the committee Amendment all
right I so the the amendment that
Senator Perkins quoka did so we had made
the ask we're we're finding not a lot of
value add from being notified by
insurance companies by Court getting
complaints were there's a lot of
redundancy we have to make sure that
it's getting paired and for complaints
and just enforcement purposes we weren't
finding a lot of value um
I think Senator Perkins kok I can't
speak for her but was a little
uncomfortable and maybe had some
conversations outside where she wasn't
quite comfortable getting rid of this
language quite yet uh maybe something we
look at going forward for next year this
is what we added back this is what we
added back so the oplc had asked that
it' be stricken and Senator Perkin quok
was not comfortable with that um so does
this conflict with any of the other
quo so and what does this this actually
do what's the effect of
this of of the language and statute oh
we when when individuals uh licensed
under the Board of Medicine are part of
a court case or a settlement agreement
board uh the oplc is notified okay so
that would just keep that notification
in place and oplc didn't feel that that
had much value or not not really not
really because we're getting the same
complaints a lot of times the insurance
complaints is we don't necessarily have
a lot of facts or information to work
off of and we could get a list of names
of individuals and we don't know who was
involved in what piece and what part so
there's not always something we can act
on in that say notification from an
insurance company so we're not we're not
particularly um there's just not a lot
of value from our perspective when we
have the complaints we have the
notifications from the courts those
types of things
represent so I'm just wondering if this
came out of the concerns that Senator
perus Koka had because we eliminated the
medical review board right yes so in in
eliminating that medical review board
what we're saying is we still want an
extra guard rail when it comes to
medical Clint especially since what
happened at Catholic Medical Center so
it's just an added um and I I understand
that concern and if this is some if this
is like language that adds a safety to
that procedure and it doesn't it doesn't
conflict with language that we've
already put into place then it's okay
and if we find that we don't use it we
don't use it but at the same time it's
there so I I do understand the concern I
understand I mean my if it's not if they
don't find it useful my inclination
would be remov it but if the Senate
feels strongly that it should stay I'm
okay with that great yeah given um given
the removal of the medical Mal practice
really review board there was a intense
interest to keep reporting by
malpractice insurers and courts to oplc
because it's not going anywhere else
okay so I'd like to do is keep going
through the if you don't need it but put
it in a box and we'll come look at it
when we need it so where is the is is
the digitally verifiable portion start
on page 39
um yes section third box down section 15
yes this so we want to strike this this
is already in 135 so um and this is who
couldn't figure out so that's I'm
fine and it goes to correct on that D
that that is the digital verifiable
portion starting on page
37 39 I'm sorry yeah the Bott the bottom
part in 39 that runs to the top part on
and just so we say it again out loud and
I'm remembering all of this I think I'm
looking straight at House Bill 1385
which has already gone to the governor
we've covered this yes we have no reason
to believe you will retail this no no
not
controversial thank you the digital
verification is not except for the
everything else the extension of a
temporary license so that people can get
right to work is all in there so would
the house be amendable to accepting our
Amendment we and we're
removing section 15 starting on page 39
all the way through the top of 43 and we
leave and then we need to add well
there's there's three other there's
three other sections side by side i'
like to go through just as okay briefly
yep um so on page 38 section 12 this is
um inspector so you wanted to change the
inspection on Barber Shop salons barber
shops and
schools once a year from twice a year is
that the middle of 38 can I speak to
that uh yes please so
um this is one of those things this was
at the office's request and essentially
right now in statute it's we're required
to inspect every shop in the state twice
a year the office had actually asked
for this to
be be stricken uh from the statue but
there was a lot of discomfort right that
sort of the what was the term used the
kitchen only clean when companies coming
over kind of things so uh we went back
and we our intent was originally to do
this in Rule and this is sort of the
negotiation between doing it twice a
year which is really not something we're
capable of doing with the amount of
staff we have right now um and making it
once a year the idea being one of those
would be tied to lure and license or
renewal and the second would be sort of
that drop in um just random inspection
to make sure people are abiding by rules
and statutes uh so this was the
negotiated piece because right now we're
required to go twice a year ah okay so
in a twoe SP I was thinking in I was
thinking every other year but no it's
twice a year no it's twice so in a
two-year licensing span we'd be in your
business four times okay this would make
it once a year so we' be there tce I'm
fine with this okay so that one's fine
and then the next one the bottom of 38
running to the top of the next
page
um okay so this just
changes
sector I I can speak to this one too
pleas so so when director Courtney when
when she originally came and recruited
me and got me on board um her intent was
to have sort of one attorney who oversaw
the legal component of
oplc um for various reasons we've
discussed that didn't work out we
created a separate Branch but she really
wants to go back to um that original
idea where there' be the executive
director there will be one sort of Chief
legal person and that person would
oversee um attorneys for the agency
attorneys for the board rule writing and
hearings and it it makes sure all these
people with these legal component are
eventually going to are ultimately going
to answer to a an attorney supervisor uh
currently director Courtney has some of
these people direct answering to her
directly which is okay because she's
also a lawyer and sort of has that
understanding the executive
director may not always be an attorney
so this kind of puts that Safeguard in
place and then simultaneously because we
had these two positions created in
statute last year the the chief and the
agency Council um modifying that board
counsel Chief position to a chief of
staff position position because the
executive director right now has a lot
of responsibility and I think the people
who work with her day and day out think
there are certain responsibilities she
could be delegating um and this would be
that sort of Chief of Staff position
that would take on and and let that
director get out of the weeds and things
like Personnel matters and those types
of things uh that currently doesn't
really exist in our office okay look and
the next one on the middle of 39 looks
like it's related is that uh
oh that was the second piece that I was
okay yeah and then and then that that
box 14 is just saying both of those
positions would answer to the executive
director all right does anybody have an
objection to I mean I
don't okay uh was representative sign I
just need to ask Mr ostad if he needed
to declare conflict of interest in
this I can't presume I'll be put in that
position
sir Okay so
I mean my understanding as it stands
actually is we would
take um HP 518 as it came out of the
actually with the Senate Amendment but
removing the amendment to section to
section
15 um and then adding in the language
from
1610 and U okay and then there's a a
procedural question I haven't I've been
on Committees of conference I haven't
shared one at this point do we actually
need to get an amendment vote on it or
vote on this intent and we'll get the
amendment vote on the intent draft
committee report reflecting that and
I'll go down to all us and get the
amendment and we all sign off after we
read it okay cool so we have V
separately yeah I understand that one
I've seen so any anything else represent
gr no I would make I would make a motion
to the house members that we okay you
guys accept that may I ask a question
before we do that so there is language
we're talking about Amendment 518
correct okay there is language in House
Bill 518 and House Bill 1622 that
modifies the same statute RSA
3108 uh we worked in the Senate with doj
very closely we would like the language
in 1622 to be the language so is this
the language that's in the amendment
1610 can I so I don't think this I think
it passed both the Senate and the house
518 in 1622 but it didn't get changed in
518 can I just make a comment we have a
committee of conference this after on
1622 we like the language of 1622 we
want to make sure the language of 518
doesn't conflict with it and if it we
don't want to end up in sort of a a
signing race so so what we would like to
do is take the language from 1622 and we
want that ultimately well I'm not I'm
not just my confusion I'm not sure
exactly what language you're talking
about is it yes I do is it the
332g language or so in on in House Bill
518 I'm looking at
the the actual bill as amended by the
Senate um page two line
moment Mr chair is it on side by side oh
no he's I don't know if it would be in
talking about 1622 right now
it won't be in the side by side if Nei
you know if the Senate didn't change it
so in in House Bill 518 as amended by
the Senate it's on page two yeah
beginning in line 14 going through line
18 can you just give us what the words
we don't have line numbers and what
we're looking at I do it's RSA 3108
Roman numeral
2 oh yeah that's a different we have
appealed RSA
31014 oh I pulled I pulled mine off the
website I'm not well actually I got it I
mean there's this is section three I
mean I printed this off the website
license renewals laps
3108 and you're the section you're
talking about is is Roman 2 correct and
uh and what it says is two licenses
shall be valid for two years from the
date of issurance except for those
apprentices licensed for one year in
accordance with rules adopted pursuant
to 541 when I provided the timely and
complete application for license
renewals by eligible applicants shall
continue the validity of the license
being renewed until the offic has acted
on the renewal application and that's
existing language and it adds or in
matters appealed pursuant to RSA 310
colon 14 until the office has issued a
final decision is that change yes so in
House Bill
1622 section one
modifies the same paragraph and this is
the language I I worked with doj on both
of these so it's different language it
is different language I can read it if
you'd like yes sir could we just strike
that entire paragraph right out of this
bill I think so there'd be no change to
in this bill there'd be no change in 518
and then 1622 would become the language
preva I'm actually looking at section
three which that's part of and that
appears to be the only oh no it's
repealed and reenacted
so but really for Section 3 is that the
only change that this is making it looks
like
that in which case we can just in the
amendment could just remove section
three um signon it could assuming that
1622 for whatever reason doesn't go down
in flames this afternoon right so I'm
looking at to see let me just look to
see what 1622 looks like before we go
yeah let's just one moment I'm looking
at that because I'm because I know I'm
on that committee conference the other
option would be to put the 1622 language
in here and then in 1622 you could pull
it
out I don't know was the only change to
that the language that we added back in
LIC no no we changed that totally which
from the Senate 162 I don't remember
that one at all I forget what that one's
dou what was 1622 1622 has to do with
the
notification of rule making remember
this is what did the Senate change I'm
looking I'm looking just a moment I see
a house version and I see an Senate
version and the sener version has the
part about license the first thing is
about license renewal laps so we just
have to make sure that we and and they
do talk about the notification of Ru
making so we just have to make sure that
in the 1622 committee conference we
leave that paragraph as is and I believe
Senator Pearl you're on that committee
with me so we're going to make sure that
we I'm going to circle this paragraph
and make sure that we keep that in 1622
and we take it out of here okay so
that's the entirety of section two
director of legislative Services
publishing amend no it talks about it's
licensed renewal laps right underneath
that
though just that one paragraph Roman two
yeah just Ro just Roman two yes the
license shall be would it make more
sense just to take that language and put
it in here to be safe and that way
there's no conflict we have consistency
between the two
bills okay it's fine oh yes just in case
something happens is okay so we could do
that can you keep track of all the stuff
yeah I'm making notes um that one that I
got to figure out what I got to find it
so I get i'll represent MTI while want
me to just forward this you you would
yeah thank you yes
um you know in 1622 Senate version it
also refers to uh RSA 310 colon
8 and is repealed two is repealed and
reenacted
so right and then it refers to RSA 54 4
RS that so that won't change and the
only change that we're seeing is the RSA
310 colon 2 I would be very careful
about that statement because this bolded
language was changed from the bill as
proposed but I don't have the language
of RSA 318 in front of me and it I would
say it would not be my style to repeal
and replace the whole section unless
there were other changes but they would
not be bolded because it'd be considered
new language so I I think the safest bet
would be take the language of 1622 that
paragraph two drop it into
518 and
then yep so we're basic we should end up
with the language we're going to replace
licenses shall be valid for two years
dot dot dot dot until the office has
issued a final decision
with licenses issued by the office shall
be valued for two years from the date of
issuance dot dot dot dot the licensing
terms established by this section self
sued any conflicting terms established
in the statute is administered by the
board listed in R you're reading that
from is that 1622 as amended by the
Senate yeah and what page in line is it
it's on page one okay it's SEC right on
section one it starts with the license
renewals and it's paragraph two licenses
issued by the office I'm looking at um
Amendment
202 I just looked up hb1 1622 and it's
showing there's something wrong they're
showing no amendments even though they
here4 go back
to you want to look at my well I want I
want to make sure I can find it so then
when I go TOS I actually have something
I can point to
um
yeah it appears in
58 section 310 we only made a change in
paragraph two amended by the if we
repeal and reenact all of that reenacted
language would be considered new and it
wouldn't show up as bolded so I would
need I'm wrote this a year ago so would
need to go back and look at I don't want
to make a mistake here that we regret
later yeah that's why I think the
safest um but where's the change this is
the language look at the CH because it's
it's um here's two
Roman it's only in section two the rest
of it appears to be the same all right
so we're doing this kind of on the Fly
and I want to make sure we don't yeah
I'm not I'm not comfortable but I
understand what's going on
so so what we're doing is we're going to
add paragraph
two on 1622 and replace this paragraph
paragraph two on 518 that's all we're
going to do that's all we're doing
that's all we're talking about yeah so
exactly and the rest the rest rest of
the amendment alone if there is a change
we're not picking up and frankly to me
this is the harder way to do it but it
is the safest way to do it if we want to
of to restrictions imposed
by okay it only goes to 31 so inside
is10 where on the side by side is
that we take we take Section out of 1622
Place into and swap it out right here
here yes exactly what I have yes then
then this representative leus this is
what I would suggest we retain Fidelity
right use section 2 1622 language and
put it into 58 simple as it okay and so
this I'm looking at 1622 as amended by
the Senate and so you're saying section
two is this is that good doesn't look
it's the
lies should be valid now you have right
um lines two through so it's actually
section one yeah I don't know what it is
in this is amended by the Senate what
I'm saying is US 1622 language whatever
section it is one I don't know but it's
section oh you're looking at
382 right so this is the Senate um uh
1622 as amended by the Senate so to read
as F and so taking section one
basically yeah but it's section
two Roman two okay so
basically yeah I just trying to get the
right way to refer to it and so to for
Olaf so what I'm what I'm saying is if
um hb1
one actually it's all of that section
one is only doing that
paragraph and then include
that yes and that's the only change
right okay so just to review what I my
understanding is that um we adopt
everything in the side by side so the
Senate Amendment the whole Senate
Amendment we keep except for section 15
yes okay we're going to add the language
from the amendment 1610 yep and we're
going to replace um this the language in
HB 518 is amended by the Senate page two
lines 14 to 18 with the uh language from
1622 is amended by the Senate um section
one which is only that part no no not
section one paragraph two we don't want
to lines two through seven right that's
all we want to do we do not want to add
section one where we say license renewal
lapse blah blah blah that's already in
here I don't know if he has the Virgin
up with the numbers on it but it's lines
two through seven on the amendment yeah
I'll have to get that with the number um
that are you guys comfortable now with
that
yes so you'll need to vote on that and
we'll vote on this we're Le in all
everything else
medical that was my only concern was
that caveat the committee members from
1622 have to remember to take that
paragraph out of I'll be there this
afternoon we don't want the same thing
they don't actually have to take it out
as long as it's the same language it
won't be a conflict okay great that's
why we're amending it to okay that's
fine perfect be no conflict then it
doesn't matter which one's signed in
language basically creating the
redundancy yeah we're just parting the
language and it doesn't matter which
one's first or last because it'll be the
same okay and actually I've got the
version now with line numbers and what
did you say for line numbers uh lines
two through seven page one lines 2
through S let me see if that looks right
to me
works all right I think I'm I'm
understand what I need to do if we all
agree I'm in agreement okay so if you
guys want to go and vote members are you
guys all good oh I think we need to talk
us for about 20 minutes if that's
no we we agree to that yes we agree on
the house side uh everybody in favor of
this yes yes anyone oppose no okay deal
deal is made and I will um go down to ol
to get this drafted and then I'll write
out I'm going to close the committee of
conference on HB
you relatively easy one accept for all
but and uh
so
uh
e
some concerns in the fact that um um
basically protecting the safet and
healthy of some of the patients and you
might have gotten this letter but it one
it created a certification requirement
for some of the um outpatient treat
treatment providers because according
there's actually a couple letters um
currently 65 there are 65 Outpatient
Treatment organizations um registered
with Medicaid and those DHHS um
contracts with nine so they're basic
they have no oversight the remaining 56
have no oversight so they had concerns
about that um we don't want another um
incident like the youth de the sen
Center so um new Futures came in with
that and the second part of it uh
establishes a behavioral health position
within the DHHS office the um budsman
now I did have a chance to read some of
the um concerns from um or not concerns
but Jennifer o Higgins from our hearing
report
um
their
um they she where's
she um she did have um detailed some of
the some of the points in this so as far
as I'm concerned um new Futures asked
for it um and I know Senator Carson um
would like to
see some of it or if not some of it if
not all of it to go
through and we have a representative
from we have Mr Barry from new Futures
would you like
to so the the uh concerns
that we'd like you to address if you
could is how this would be managed
within
HHS and I know that you're a
representative from HHS is not here sure
and maybe you could also address the
concerns that for example I would
imagine that the certification program
is to make sure that all the recovery
facilities or substantive utilities
operate on the same
standard and if they have to be
licensed how is it that we need this
added so that's the question how if we
already have the individuals certified
and they're supposed to be operating on
the same standard why do we need an
additional certification program sure I
think that would
help yeah okay
ahead there we go all right thank you um
that's it all right um so as you know
new Futures has been working to address
substance use and addiction in our state
for over 25 years we've been working on
this bill with Senator Carson and other
supporters going back to last summer um
just to provide some clarity where this
came from you may have uh seen or heard
where the 13th Step which was a an
award-winning podcast series from New
Hampshire public radio that detailed
patterns and and culture of sexual
assault and harassment with one of our
largest treatment networks in the State
uh let me be clear the treatment Network
in question in that podcast was a
residential treatment program largely
Residential Services which are not
covered by this bill because residential
facilities are already licensed but what
that podcast did expose was a a sort of
a long held um a little known secret
within the substance use treatment World
about a lack of oversight over another
class of treatment providers being
Outpatient Treatment in our state uh for
outpatient treatment providers there um
there is individual lure for clinicians
which I'll come back to in a moment um
but beyond that there is no facility
licensing there is no facility
certification currently there is no um
oversight and as Senator burel mentioned
for a great many of these providers
there's no record within the state of
where they provide what class of
services or what quality of services
they provide or who they are um we
really see that as leaving you know
these these patients who are at their
most vulnerable point being at risk for
abuses or misconduct or at at minimum
substandard service which is something
that impacts not only their own recovery
but the quality of our entire treatment
Network across the board we spend a a a
great great deal of money to prop up
this treatment Network to ensure these
services are provided in folks but it's
really only as strong as the weakest
provider and we really want to make sure
that everybody's operating by the same
standards the same qualities of care and
so on and again right now there's no
real way of ensuring that um as far as
mentioned earlier there is individual
clinician lure within the state and
individuals can be held responsible but
what we have heard word of around the
state are organizations that we'll say
play a little bit loose with the rules
and which uh um you know they are
crowding group therapy sessions far
beyond the ratios that are considered to
be best practice um they are employing
um recovery professionals who are not so
far along in their own recovery that
they are not supposed to be providing
that level of support or Services which
again leaves them leaves them at risk as
well as their patients uh if individual
folks are the only people held
responsible for this if they are removed
uh there's still incentive for the these
organizations to just put somebody else
in the same position to do the same
thing which leaves the the clinician I
mean leaves the patients at risk again
for these abuses and misconduct uh so
this really is intended to to plug that
hole in sort of oversight or authority
to ensure that the that the state can uh
know who these again who these providers
are where they're operating and really
try to hold them
to certain standards of of service in
order to U prop up their own service and
again make sure that our entire network
which again we work so hard to fund uh
is is uh providing quality services
across the board um and so to make sure
that folks are getting the treatment
that they need and that we're making
good use of the money that we are
spending on our treatment services does
questions thank you for being here uh
and thanks for taking my question um
so from my understanding nobody's
opposed to the idea of the bill but
still the house Health and Human
Services committee came out with a 191
recommendation for interim study sure
the one person wanting to kill the bill
altogether so the vast majority of the
people felt like this needed more work
and I was assured by them that they plan
on doing that work um can you speak into
the concerns that you've heard from that
committee at all and why they want to
move this to interum study and their
concerns about this language because we
don't have anybody here I'm I'm I'm
happy yes and I do I believe that my
colleague that Mr Higgins from DJJ is on
her way I think she's aiming to be here
to answer some of these questions there
were questions raised in uh with the
health house Health and Human Services
committee around uh who would be held to
these certification requirement what
class of providers there was some um I
would say some misunderstanding about uh
you know this bill is really intended to
Pro apply to Clinical Services only it's
not it does not apply to Alcoholics
Anonymous it does not apply to other
self-help groups um that has not been
spelled out in the Lang that had not
been spelled out in the language of the
bill um because we thought that the
reference to clinical patient services
with suffice but there were some
questions and and again I would say some
misunderstandings around that there is
absolutely no intention here to apply to
uh again AA self-help other non-clinical
services like that I did work uh with
certain committee members on an
amendment that ultimately didn't did not
get put forward on language that would
clarify uh who which which classes of
providers this would apply to as well as
uh what exemptions exist uh the this
Lang and I'm happy to share this
language with you if that would be
helpful clarifies that um again res
residential services are exempt because
they're already covered by facility
licensing individual practitioners are
exempt because they're already covered
by individual professional lure um and
uh again self-help and AAA another
program other group programs like that
are exempt because again that's just not
the intention of this bill in any way
I'm happy to share that that that was
the Crux of some of the questions we
heard thank you um so that was part of
the discussion though and how and Human
Services it it was okay and and at the
end of that you were not able to assuage
their concerns that this didn't apply to
those groups from the sounds of things
because they moved 191 to interim study
so it was part of the conversation but
it didn't resolve the issue to be the
simple fact it we ran out of time that
it was supposed to be a second commune
bill and the deadline was was you know
was was that afternoon we had um the
hearing I think was held 5 days before
the deadline or something along those
lines and the simple fact was that that
we ran out of time time uh and uh to
address the concerns that were raised I
was hopeful that this um this amendment
uh that we had worked on would address
them but um the committee felt that they
just didn't have enough time uh what I
would say U certainly we appreciate the
intentionality of of uh uh uh the
legislature and taking its time with
this but there there's some urgency here
the longer that we have people out there
attending these these unregulated
uncertified uh treatment providers again
the more at risk they are again for for
misconduct abuses substandard services
and again that more them that more the
more that costs them individually and it
state um having said that do you have
statistics as far as um incidences in
the licens OR own license facilities
that would indicate the urgency so you
know um you're saying there's urgency
because there's danger of things
happening is that happening at a
prolific level outside of theu Center
obviously but in other areas or we're
just noticing that it could again it's
it's impossible to know which is why
part of why we're here because there is
no mechanis there's no oversight
mechanism there's no ability for the
state to track these things to to take
those kind of complaints currently
that's what we're trying to put into
place here thank you sure you
representative goul and thenes Senator
prenis thank you Senator penis no
representative gr then Senator prce
thank you um thank you thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so I remember a few years ago
an Expose and I don't think it was the
NPR thing but maybe it was and I was
praying somebody would be here with a
better memory and more active in the
field than I have been for many many
years but it was about a young Dynamic
individual who created a very exciting
program and about many workers that got
involved and were really really excited
about a addressing the very serious
substance abuse issues we have in New
Hampshire
but then a funny thing happened and
money kind of got in the way and and the
numbers were being increased and
increased and increased and increased
and the pressure on the workers was
becoming more and more intense and it
finally got to the point that it was
very abusive to both the staff and the
participants in the program and I I
don't recall the name of the program but
I do remember it was a serious concern
well my question for you is that I'm
really concerned about is that if we are
relying on the licenses of individual
clinicians to follow their requirements
in providing services but we have no
oversight none zero oversight on the
entity hiring them we then are putting
those clinicians in the position of
having to be the oversight for agencies
that pay them a salary is that correct
am I understanding that correctly
yes representative know that that's
absolutely right if there you know and
and again what we there's been sort of
an unkempt secret within the treatment
world and we heard this uh in you know
in testimony at the house you know the
house hearing the Senate hearing from
all kinds of treatment providers that um
you know our best treatment providers in
the state or treatment providers all
over the state are serving patients who
are coming from other programs that that
were did not receive the level of care
and support that they needed and this
you know this makes it more challenging
more timec consuming and more expensive
for these programs to to to be able to
get these people on a path to recovery
who have already been through um at best
case substandard service at worst case
trauma coming out of some of these
things and
um because there are certain and and I I
don't think there are many of them and
again we're really just we're going by
anecdotes because we haven't an
inability to track it but there are some
uh treatment providers in the state
where there's just a culture of chasing
some of the money that you're talking
about and and let's make no mistake
there um there's a fair amount of money
available through Medicaid which and
thank God it is that's what supports our
entire network but there are some folks
who are driven more by that the
potential Revenue than they are by care
for patients um and to put to hold an
individual clinician responsible for the
culture of an organization that is out
there sacrificing quality of service for
um for the the bottom line for revenues
is
um not only I think somewhat misplaced
and and a little irresponsible in a way
to chase quality clinicians out of the
field and in my
view thank you very much for that uh I
have another question somewhat related
to make sure I'm understanding or that
my understanding is accurate in some of
these organizations don't we have a
mixture of licensed clinicians and kind
of peer-to-peer
or um sort of the self-help aspect that
you were referring to so um so that we
would have licensed clinicians being
held to a standard an agency not held to
any standard and then self-help level
kind of people that are not licensed
that are in there also not held to any
standard is that
correct I'm I want to make sure I
understand the question but it certainly
sounds none of these things are mut
exclusive right you can you know you do
have some um Treatment Center you know
treatment provider organizations that
provide outpatient residential treatment
and they will provide some level of
recovery support either inhouse or
either through a contract with a
recovery Community organization or
something along those lines so yeah and
some of them will do you know provide um
just clinical treatments some will
provide
um so what I'm looking for religious
based treatment which is which is again
not considered clinical but it's another
it's it's another approach so there you
know there is certainly a mix of
providers across the board but this
isn't again intended to provide only to
those folks to those organizations that
provide uh clinical Treatment Services
uh and not not getting into self-help
and others last
followup okay thank you so so thank you
I think that confirms what I'm saying my
point being that we have licensed
clinicians who are sandwiched in some
cases between um organizations that are
unregulated who who control their bread
and butter their paycheck their their
support for their family and and other
sideline uh services that might be
incorporated into the agency that are
also unlicensed practitioners who are
out there performing whereas if we had
licensed providers and licensed
clinicians these um self-help sort of
aspects of a program would have two
layers of supervision a clinician stuck
in the middle and and if I can add um
that that's really the intention of the
second provision of of what was sen Bill
495 related to the position with the EMB
budman's office is to ensure that there
is a dedicated sort of place that staff
members is in addition to patients can
go when they are witnessed to are being
asked to provide substandard service
right that they um uh uh we want to make
sure that that we have somebody who is
properly trained and equipped to respond
to those kind of complaints because
again we we know it's out there and
hopefully if we put the certification
and Regulatory system in place there
will be more complaints coming
in Senator
princess thank you representative Broda
and um um thank you Jake uh Mr Barry for
taking my questions um so you are
talking here about we've got these
providers that
are are we've got these providers that
are out floating between different what
would currently be defined as facilities
providing care but the care the care
treatment services but the centers or
facilities that they're providing
treatment Cent treatment at are not
licensed so there's no regulatory
oversight but the Prov I think I'm
repeating what's already been said but
I'm going somewhere to make sure I've
got this clear so we have all the
providers but no Mothership to be
Tethered to from a li insure and a
quality control perspective correct if
there is a complaint filed against right
now if there is again substandard
Treatment Services being applied to
we're not we're not sticking to clinical
standards and so on the only complaint
that can be filed is against the
individual practitioner which again does
not address the issue if you are if
there's an organization that is uh
inspired to uh uh purposely evade these
these treatment standards uh and I hope
this answers some of the question c um
but we you know again there are some we
know of some
provider organizations that are
motivated by Revenue by bottom lines uh
as much as they are more so than they
are patient care which leads them to
kind of flout uh treatment standards and
it is not an issue in individual
clinician it is an organizational issue
so if you have if there is a clinician
that is removed they would potentially
be placed with someone else who will
again similarly flout those those
Service uh standards and leave patients
at risk
does that answer the question it's it's
it makes sense to me so um
followup so U Mr Barry would it be your
position that um alcohol and drug use
are public health emergencies health and
Public Safety emergencies in the state
certainly so and I would think that by
the you know again the amount of time
and resources that have been devoted in
the state over the last 10 years to
build a treatment system uh that is
capable of I think that
it seems to me the state as a whole
recognizes this as a public health
emergency and again this is I would
argue this is just part of the natural
maturation of the system we have tried
to uh to put in place to make sure that
we are protecting um everyone in our
state especially the most vulnerable
Among Us who are in need of these
services and again to make sure the
money we're spending is being well spent
and well guarded thank you Al I will
note that my uh Miss from DHHS is here
now as well would you like to join Mr
so I I'd like to take the conversation
after listening to everybody in into
this vein so the state is invested in
drug and alcohol abuse substance abuse
correct and um the F facilities receive
money for those to support that the work
that they do but those facilities are
independent of any kind of certification
or registration that we have with in the
state so although we give them funding
we really don't
know their per let's just call it their
performance record or
their treatment record is that or the
way they treat people is that correct so
this bill actually just expands those
that even don't have state funding So
currently if you have receive state
funding there is some amount of oversite
or the ability to certify those who
receive funding but we know there to be
um at least six 5 outpatient facilities
registered with Medicaid and of those
only nine receive funding through the
state so the oversight piece doesn't
exist for others that operate as an
outpatient
clinic and if I can note those are only
the ones that take Medicaid when we
think about all of the you know those
that that do not they are not on the map
anywhere they they there's no contract
there's no record within the state of of
them
whatsoever okay does that
um lead the committee to any questions
that they might have in their mind yes
representative berel thank you very much
um so I I'm looking in looking at the
bill this bill requires that do we not
already have an armed budsman department
for this
particular um we do so anything that
falls under DHHS can fall the current um
budsman because this bill would be uh
inclusive of of those outpatient
facilities for whom do not receive state
funding we they then those Services
would then fall under the current um
budsman this bill does add a position
that would have more expertise in the
area of Behavioral Health within the
existing ombudsman's office
followup so and I'm I'm looking at the
language and it says subject to
available funding the department shall
designate within the office of um
budsman a person as Behavioral Health so
that's they'll only assign it if they
have the fin the funding for it correct
okay thank you it if I can note that you
know we should note that there's no
appropriation attached this bill there's
no dollars and cents really what this
does is Task the the department with
going through rul making with create you
know with creating the certification
standards this is beginning a process
that will um uh uh that will ultimately
result in the the certification
Authority but but this is the this is
the beginning of a process
representative Simon
thank you there's no appropriation per
se to it but it does give the ability to
to Levy fees on on facilities
correct yes so if we were to adopt the
rules but because there is the
contingency language and there of
subject to available funding we would
have to know the department would have
to know that we have the staff to
actually certify these facilities and
oversee their quality before we would
adopt the rules right because we
wouldn't want to start saying you have
to be certified if could not understand
the quality of your programming then we
would be you know just certifying places
and sort of giving a false sense of
security that they have oversight so
until such time as we would have the
staff to do the oversight then we would
adopt those rules so again like to
Jake's point it's the baby step of we
need there's so much details that need
to be figured out about what would be in
a certification program that it allows
us to start to work with facilities to
figure out what needs to be in the rul
making and then at such time as there is
available funding to do to have the
Staffing to certify and oversee the
quality we could
Implement okay Senator burel one last
question so let me just get this
straight so um this is just opening up
the door to looking at the rules and
setting up the process and then possibly
next year during the budget process
putting the funding in if everything's
lined up at that point then next year
during the funding budget process
putting the money into the budget for
you so let if I could if I could follow
up with
that this is this is important I think
this is an important part of the
discussion If This Were to be added what
it allows the um Department to do the
agent to do is to start putting together
a
program because without that you really
can't ask for funding because you won't
have anything to to ask for right and
but if you don't get the funding then
this can't happen because you won't be
able to fund
it okay so my question is if we have 65
this is if we have 65 registered
facilities that take Medicare and nine
are funded by the stat so we have
purview over those nine that means we
have 55 that don't what's the incentive
for those
55 to be
to what's see what would is it just
because we're putting it in statue that
they have to do it and and then what
didn't in the state without this
certification so there the incentive is
to practice but um ultimately that's
also just those are the Medicaid that
those who take Medicaid numbers again
are just giving us an estimate of the
scope of work that's happening that
we're unsure about so I think Mr Barry
also had mentioned how just
understanding the landscape of treatment
services is an important step forward
for New Hampshire because when we get a
call from you know someone who needs
Services when we don't know where
they're all located and the quality of
them it's very hard to make a referral
so those who we do know who receive
state funding
who we work closely with and collaborate
with today or who is going to receive
all of the referrals through those State
programs but understanding the landscape
and quality of treatment services also
expands where we can refer people and
even if they don't receive you know take
Medicaid there are lots of folks who
have other health insurance who still
need treatment so expanding our
understanding of the landscape of care
goes a long way for us as a state as
well okay that's helpful and I really
believe representative Simon has a
question
thank you I appreciate it um so this
this ultimately if I'm understanding it
correct correctly is a facility
license certification but it's it's
similar to a license um in order to be
able to hold um these facilities
accountable to certain standards now um
I'm I'm assuming even though they're not
certified under the state of New
Hampshire are there things that they
could do that would be considered
illegal and criminal from a facility
standpoint that the state could step in
somebody came to the utsman from one of
these facilities and says this is
happening in this facility and it's
illegal that the facility could still be
held accountable to that illegality is
is that correct or multiple layers exist
in terms of the the clinician's license
so the licensing board plays a part if
the facility is residential it's already
licensed so we're talking about the
outpatient piece so if a facility is
licensed then there's a way to you know
issue a complaint that would be covered
by both the um budsman and our licensing
unit um if the if this facility receives
State funding yes it falls under the EMB
budsman and the Bureau of drug and
alcohol services but the other other
operators who don't fall into those
categories exist without that oversight
there is the way that they you could
report the clinician to the licensing
board or um criminal activity of course
could be reported to law enforcement if
I could add representative uh certainly
I think you criminal activity is not the
only standard here in the worst case
certainly is but we're really trying
what we're trying to talk about is uh
quality of service and ensuring that
people are being held to service
standards that again uh help people to
achieve their recovery uh help these
organ you know and help organizations
all across the network do their job of
getting people into into recovery and
again uh which which helps individuals
but also assures that our state
investment in this is is money well
spent right so so do I understand that
the the data is a
problem but it would be helpful to me in
in making this decision to know that the
facilities that are presently under the
jurisdiction of the department and have
oversight are producing per capita
better outcomes for their patients than
those who are not we have no information
whatsoever about those who are not right
so but what you're asking us to do is to
then give you authority over all of them
when I have no indication that the ones
that are under your control are doing
better than the ones that are outside of
your
control correct we have again we will
have no idea as a state about the
outcomes of those that we do not have a
contract with without granting some
Authority so is there is there a step in
between where we start to G to gather
information before we just change the
entire
system sure okay I I
I again we can certainly talk about that
I don't know how you gather information
from these programs without some level
of
uh contact connection some some some
level regulation of what we're talking
about here I think again that's the very
intention of this and I I would say in
the absence of this data all that we
have are the the testimony and
experiences of the service providers
themselves and again they have they they
showed up throughout this process to to
say they desperately need this they
desperately want this um this is not
opposed by a single uh treatment or
recovery or Healthcare organization in
the state that I'm aware of because they
they think this is absolutely essential
to ensuring the level of service across
the board thank you guys appreciate it
representative PR has a question well
kind of a question and a statement so to
be able to get the information you need
you're going to need Authority given to
you by us so you can collect that data
and actually make them give you that
data because they're not going to give
it if they don't have to I would
assume I think that's that's very much
part of the intention here for sure
right so you need our The Authority
collect the data to make sure they're
doing what they're supposed to and
providing a level of care to the
standard right I get that just wasn't
bill so my um let's park this for a
second because this is something we
should be will'll think about um and
we're not going to be done by 12:00 I
doubt but let's go to um the second bill
that was added to this which is
independent
question no no no
please and follow up in the line of
questioning just want to go back to the
threat to Public Health so let me ask
this a little bit differently these
folks who are
treatment correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe what I heard you say is that
they are in Jeopardy or they are in
danger because we have no true oversight
over the organizations just the
providers and there's an inherent
problem in that system
correct that's our feeling and certainly
the feeling of treatment providers
around the state for sure okay thank
you that PP me too that's my concern and
uh my concern that's twofold number one
we want to protect the public number two
the state is investing a lot of money
and if we are not and if we are limited
to the number of people that the number
of facilities that we can refer people
to that really impedes the progress that
we have towards resolving this issue but
my other question so my question is are
there other states that have this type
of program and might you tell us a
little bit about
that um what what path they took and
what what the results were from there
because it's not going to be like the
people of New Hampshire are uniquely
different than the people in another
state right we're all people so is there
do you have some some information
there yes so I think generally substance
use disorder care has been largely
unregulated throughout the nation so New
Hampshire is not unique in um in having
some of these same challenges and there
are certainly states that have
certification or licensing that are
inclusive of outpatient care and we
would be able to look at examples of
that to use for R making or inciting for
you all to re review to figure out our
way forward in New
Hampshire okay does any yes Senator
Pearl I don't actually have a question U
we're going to have to be done here by
new we all have other places we have to
go okay then let's just hop over then to
Senate Bill 27 27 sorry to rush us along
but we're on really tight schedule but
well
yes I understand so um Mr Hawkins do you
want to come and Hawkings come and so
what was
the so this bill was actually um amended
by the house education committee from an
incentive program to a grant
program and then it
was um it me me its untimely um demise
in the house finance committee but I
think
um perhaps
um we can explain to the committee or
maybe the house can can the senate can
speak to why they added it and then
maybe U Mr Hawkins can speak to the fact
that this is something that's paid back
right I'm sorry something that is I
think this is a loan program that's paid
back is that right or no it is a loan
repayment right U yeah
okay well this was I believe Senator
Fenton's Bill if I'm not mistaken and
and I'm happy to to speak to what you're
on education yes all right we let you
we'll let you take this PO okay thank
you um
so whether it's a grant that they have
to pay back or a loan that they have to
pay back an incentive or a grant the
teacher
shortage committee or
commission uh made this as a
recommendation that you know we know we
have a shortage of educators of teachers
and they and Senator Fenton filed has
been working on this for almost two
years to try to get this into into place
to support and it's primarily targeted
for the more rural District in this
state U and it talks about you know the
rural districts in the state the size of
the schools I mean all of that is in
here and you know we're looking to
resuscitate this because of its really
its importance we know we have a
shortage of teachers we had a commission
it was a committee so I don't want to
I'm not trying to use those
interchangeably I wasn't on it but
Senator Ward shared it and former
Senator Khan was on it and this was a
key recommendation focused on the more
rural areas of the state so it's about
making an investment whether we're
making it as a you know offering it as a
loan to do payback and you know through
an incentive program or a grant did we
need to do something okay and so maybe
Finance was concerned with the money but
you know well that's your job to be
concerned with the money and the
appropriation but we've got to do my
opinion is we've got to do something
this is critical we know that it is and
we just keep kicking it down the road so
here's its final stop this year yeah
yeah so I have a question on so my
comment on this was with the is this
Senate version the one that has the
loan as opposed to the
grant yeah because would the Senate
object
to um
the this being a the house version as
opposed to the Senate version I'm I'm
question so this looks like it's an
incentive see it as okay I'm sorry it's
an incentive and we the house changed it
to a grant I apologize the was incentive
right but there's a dollar yeah arguably
yes so and and the budget the the
um and really this is another
so my thinking on this is that because
we've put a dollar in there right and if
we don't fund the fund it doesn't
happen and so this becomes a decision of
the fiscal of the of the finance
committee and this is actually a policy
and the policy was passed by the
committee so I I'm in support of
this bill this portion of it because it
becomes a policy then therefore needs to
be funded and whether or not Finance
funds it depends on much how much money
we have and that doesn't be that becomes
a financial issue does that make sense
to
everybody are we all in agreement with
my and
was I was very it was a beautiful
Soliloquy if I might add so um what I
was thinking was because this is really
a policy issue this is really setting up
a program which is a policy issue and
the house
education committee passed this right
which is unusual for the house education
committee to pass something and that
they agree
on it's been a tough year in education
and so I think that we should all I'd
like to honor this amend this request
but I'd like it to be the house version
if we could do that and then we will
leave it up to finance next year to put
it in the budget and if they choose to
put it in the budget they choose to put
it in the budget if they choose not to
put it in the budget it doesn't go so
but at least we don't impede does that
you no it has a dollar in there yes
you're on the similar track to I was I
mean this this should be a budget year
issue my opinion
yes thec but the policy could go through
yes I don't have an issue with the
policy I just have an issue with the
funding that we do in off years um in
general I mean I'm not having an issue
with this bill but if if the house was
agreeable to putting the policy in and
leaving the funding out I I don't I'm
not sure that we as a senate would have
a huge issue with that because then we
could take it up in the budget next
year sorry how about we make this just
two bills instead of three just calm
wor okay so the Senate version was at a
dollar I guess we didn't put any money
in no no it has always been a dollar
so there's no money in here we're just
right
there's sorry I'll give the
dollar what's the difference between the
the
Senate theate budget and the house
budget no the Senate version and the
house version the house version must
have had money attached to it no no no
verion turned it into a grant as opposed
to an incentive program okay that was
the only difference is that correct Mr
Hawkings can help us here yeah I think
you essentially described it uh the idea
was the same
um the difference just being the Senate
policy being a a graduated loan
repayment the uh senates didn't
stipulate loan it was more of a
incentive
retention um Grant same amounts and
everything like that um but it didn't it
didn't uh ground that into a repayment
of Al loan so it looked a little bit
more like you know in hb2 this year you
you did an incentive for a computer
science uh I it looked a little bit more
of like that I would say I mean um than
but the idea was the same you know
trying to help uh retain and uh recruit
Educators in Rural and underserved areas
so so I had a long conversation with
representative cordelli who's a CO
co-sponsor on this bill and his he was
the one that amended it in he education
and he called it more of a grant type
program as opposed to an incentive
program but the concept of a policy to
attract teachers to underserved
areas is similar and he he supports that
so
um I just let me try to find the house
so if we were to give you that change
support the remainder of the bill as
prate Bill 217 we would add to you
support the remainder of 1079 as the
Senate amended it okay so the 1079
Amendment let me just how are we feeling
about this is another one where we have
no money and it's a policy issue because
we're not this is not funded right now
correct we're talking about sorry we're
talking about we're talking about s Bill
495 so we're going to the so what you're
saying is if if we agree to amend to
take the house language of the last part
yeah will you give us the rest of the
yes my concern
um we have three different moving Parts
in this two of them were rejected by the
house one of them was accepted by the
house no one of them inance that
what the original bill was no that one
was accepted 495 with interance Stud yes
but the original bill was was moved out
to pass we passed that bill right yes
and they've also passed that Bill yes
yes right yes we have that's and to me
that's an important piece of legislation
I I worked very hard on that bill as
representative pros and we worked to get
that through um my concern on the 1079
language is first
bipartisanly in the house Health and
Human Services committee they moved 191
to interim study in my few minutes of
having the discussion here I feel like
it's more complicated than just a
straightforward here's a good program
let's not that I'm opposed to the idea
of obviously improving substance abuse
but if we attach that and we attach this
to bills that the house rejected we can
agree to it here but if it goes to the
house and gets shot down because some
people don't like the education
component and some people don't like um
substance abuse program we're going to
lose all of it we're not going to get
any of it and and I'd hate to lose the
original language and and we can't
control that like I I have no control
over whether or not the house is going
to AED to that to that language so I
feel like we're putting at risk an
important bill um when Health and Human
Services in the house is very committed
to working on 1079 to come out with
language that will work um and I mean I
I actually like the education component
I'm not oppos po the education part of
it at all my concern is the saying goes
you know like you need all kinds of
reasons to vote for something you only
need one reason to vote against it and
I'm just worried that we're setting up
opposition to the underlying bill by
passing all of it so I'd be agreeable to
leaving on principle I'd be agreeable to
leaving the the education component in
I'm I'm personally opposed to leaving
the middle section in on 1079 uh to the
point where not because once again not
we need solutions to that problem but um
I'd probably need to be replaced if the
committee wanted to pass that through so
so the thing I would say is I I
understand your concern and there
there'll be a filing period coming up in
six months where if this does pass that
tweaks to it could be made relatively
quickly within a year and so um you know
I don't think there's a danger even if
there is some minor tweaks that need to
be done to the middle section I think
that the ability is there HHS won't have
things in place rule making done before
we could actually put another bill in
and change it you know the HHS committee
could certainly do that and uh that
those changes could probably occur
before rul making ever going in the
program was even stood
up so if there's real concerns that
about some piece some element of it
there is an opportunity to correct it I
don't share those concerns but if there
if there are members of the house that
feel there are and Health and Human
Services wants to take that on they'd
have the ability to do so well my main
concern is that there appear to be a lot
of members of the house that hold that
concern and I'm just I'm just thinking
numerically you know as as far as
getting something done this year well
that's your selling point on the
floor but I just wrote your floor spee I
I might add I think what what was
attached is maybe a little bit different
than what actually went through Health
and Human Services because here it's
only um putting the rules together it's
not it's not adding the the IND the
person in we're just putting the rule
we're just allowing Health and Human
Services put the rules together we're
not implementing the program as of yet
well some I mean and I did have a
confusion on this point maybe somebody
from the Senate can help me out on it um
let me find the page real quick sorry
because I understand that we are putting
was if you're concerned about maybe if
you're concerned about the uh language
in there say if funding available we can
strike that and just leave the leave
the it's not it wasn't funding per se
but if you look on page 14 um Roman
numeral 4 it says all fees received from
certification under this section so I'm
assuming it's an assumption that that
means that that during the rul making
process they'll be granted the authority
to to Levy fees uh against the
facilities that they're overseeing for
certification and it should be kept in a
non-aps fund known as the substance use
Treatment Certification fund so we're
going to we're going to allow them to
set fees we've put no caveats to what
those fees are um at least with oplc
it's 25% above operating cost your caps
there's no cap here so I mean maybe we
could do something with that but there's
no cap here and it's a non-aps fund with
no cap to the non-aps fund so it's a
fund that money can go into with no
limit to it what whatsoever
um and I not
sure I don't see anywhere in here where
to authorize to put a fee uh what's P
well help me out that's what I'm saying
maybe I'm confused you can page 14 Roman
numeral 4 can we bring HHS back yeah I'd
love to yeah I just I need clarification
on it yeah says all fees received from
certification under the section correct
that is there yeah may I ask a question
of course I ask oh yes you may you may
sorry does this language allow you to
assess a certification fee so I do I do
think it would if we adopted rules on
this and so but until such time as we
had the staff to implement the
certification we wouldn't adopt the
rules I think if the rules are adopted
the fee the details of the amount of the
fee and if there was a cap on that and
all of that would be worked out in the
rle making portion which we intend to do
with providers so we've started that
process of talking with providers about
like what would make sense we obviously
have a big stake in the game for their
financial viability so we need to be
careful to not like we need to make sure
that there is adequate treatment in our
states so we're not looking for a fee
that would then put them out of business
right it would need to be on a scale
based on their size and all of that as
well um so that's some of the role
making that would need to be done that's
where all a lot of that detail happens I
I read through this pretty quickly I see
no place in here where it authorizes you
to set up a fee
schedule maybe I'm mistaken and I'm
missing it I think it does right there
in room making when they say they can
set up a fee that's that's part of the
the fee schedule is in the room making
and we're not we're not providing any
oversight to that whatsoever and so I
understand well wait a minute we are
providing oversight because jel car does
have oversight for that right so we do
have we do and as a member of Jael car I
can tell you that we are very very um
keen on that type
of of of uh schedule because we deal
with it with oplc all the time and we're
very we are very um concerned about fee
schedules and agency setting fees so I
do think that would be um an area of
concern to Jael car and the agency and
the Jael car um Department the
Department thank you madam chair so
could we just add a line in in here that
are we all in agreement that adding a
line about a cap on the fees or
something to satisfy those
concerns this is my first Committee of
conference so I'm it's a technical
question can we add language so so I
think my my concern with that is we'd
have we'd be really just throwing a d
we'd have no idea what to do with that I
i' more Trust yel car to look at it and
assess the program correctly when they
have the time to do so more than us
today sitting here and deciding so could
we add a line about J the jail car
process in okay so let me just explain
how the jail how the ru making process
goes if the agency had the authority to
implement this program they would work
with their providers to put together the
rules and then but there would be public
hearings on those rules right and then
what and there would also be review of
those Rules by the administrative rule
department and then the comment public
comments and the comments from the um
agent from the administrative Department
upward together and presented to to Jael
car and Jael car can object they can
express their concerns and one of the
things they can express their concerns
of is the fee so those those all that
stuff has to be justified and has to be
um supported by Statute right Madam
chair yes so my my concern was I mean we
all know the process but um referring to
representative Simon's concerns about
the how House the full house
understanding that that was where my
question was could we put something in
this language that would reassure people
I mean we face this all the time is the
ignorance on the regulatory process and
even though we understand it and that
passing a bill doesn't give everybody
willy-nilly access to run out and start
doing we know other people don't
understand that regulatory process Madam
chair yes we want a five minute caucus
absolutely and then we'll be right
absolutely and one of the things I do
want to mention is that in the Health
and Human Services committee
representative Weber did put together an
amendment um that was
[Music]
um acceptable to the Democratic caucus
except for one person who really didn't
understand the fact that these that you
could have licensed people with
unregistered facilities right but I
think that's an issue that I can
certainly clear up with them so we do
have an amendment if representative
Barry wants to discuss it when you go
back but I I just want to give you that
information I'm okay trying to I think
this is important but I'm trying to keep
everything in balls and one in the air
without having one plop on the floor and
five
e
I mean senator of
pearl you're going back to my
past well Madam chair we've uh We've
caucused and we've recognized that the
uh the concern that is on the house
floor about the underlying bill of 1079
we certainly want to make sure that gets
passed and give it every chance we can
because it's very important I guess my
question to you is can you provide me a
degree of assurance that Senate Bill 495
will actually have some interim study
work from the house HHS committee yes
you have my word and you also have a
word of Representative Simon who is um
so you have a democratic word and a
republican word that we will push that
because not I do we do think it's very
important as way of reassurance one of
the members one of the higher ranking
members of the committee um I I spoke to
on that said that they they plan on
doing a tremendous amount of work on
that they really do want to get it right
and this person would just tell me
straight up if they wanted to gut it and
kill it and just leave it off on the
roadside to be like no we just want this
thing dead this person would tell me
that uh in a private confidential
conversation if that's what they
actually wanted because they'd want me
to do that here um but that wasn't the
feedback that I got just that they ran
out of time they really wanted to vet
this more closely and get it right and
make sure that it was done correctly and
that they it was a true interim study
not a not a soft kill well with that I
think that we could be yep sorry um so
and I also spoke with um Jake and J um
they actually have um Jenny does have
some homework that she has to do kind of
in advance um working with some of the
providers so I told them I gave them my
word that we would do it in stepbystep
process not eat the apple whole at one
time and just start with the rules and
set up the program so we can work
together perfect keep me in mind for
that that the Senate would be agreeable
to the original language of 1079 and the
last portion and I'm sorry I don't have
the 219 217 that language being added to
1095 and we'd be in agreement with
removing the language that was from SP
sp495 from the bill okay so I just want
to I don't want to push my luck because
this so far we're going well three a
yeah so but you're talking about the
Senate version of Senate Bill 117 as
opposed to the house I mean 2 217 Senate
Bill 217 the Senate version as opposed
to the house version I don't know that
we have a concern one way or the other
yeah because it Grant versus what if
you're more comfortable with the house
version and I helps you on the floor
then we have to do okay let's just but
that's great so it's a house version of
sand Bill 217 that came out of the house
education committee and 1079 as
submitted correct as amended by the sen
we did that other than you know removing
the I don't remember if we made an
amendment to that we did not you so yes
so the the U house version of 1079 and
and we'll and the house version of 217
yes we'll agree to remove the other
portion okay thank you so I have
agreement from the Senate do I have
agreement from the
house reluctantly yes okay thank you
this concludes the committee of
conference and excellent thank you thank
e
[Music]
great good
well all right house house bill 1622 on
administrative rulemaking and license
renewals etc
etc um we mostly agree with the Senate
Amendment and we do have a couple of
issues that we'd like to bring to your
yeah there it's the Cannabis group
they're going to be
loud uh section two has which is RSA
3108 Roman
2 the language is fine but it's already
been included in House Bill 518 as of
this morning so we'd like to get rid of
this if that's agreeable with you guys I
don't mind if we do but is there any
issue with having it passed twice just
to make sure we didn't make a
mistake well if we did make a mistake it
would be bad because it would be random
chance on whether the good version or
the bad version came out first right but
no I I'm I'm fine with that I mean
representative leus I just haven't seen
the language that's why I was hesitant
to remove it oh well
it's I haven't seen the amendment that
he's drafting that was my just to make
sure it was correct since you will be
signing it off this afternoon both of
them I have to so okay I'm fine with
that you have any objection to that we
took that exact same language and
amended I SP
58 yes all right and then skipping on
the page side by side over to
page
um
seven there's uh the version of how the
the comments were to be incorporated in
the rule I have a draft
everybody that
um that spreads
out
and let us a do it explains that the
comments are
uploaded duplicate comments may be
Consolidated you know when you say we've
got you know 157 copies of this email
from the Sierra Club or whatever or or
the gun
group there's no need to to post them
individually or if seven people write
separately that you know this rule is
pretty good but I don't like the fine in
section 12 you just
consolidate and then vulgar or
inappropriate testimony may not be
published it's just just for dis
discretion and
adds that comments received as video or
audio files shall be available in that
format they don't have to to
transcribe voicemail or anything like
that but if somebody sends them a file
e um I got some very nice language from
Jael car staff that says a report of
public comments received on the rule
shall be created the report shall
indicate how the comment was
incorporated into the final rule the
comment was not incorporated into the
final rule the agency shall provide a
detailed explanation that includes the
facts data interpretations and policy
choices that justify why the adopting
agency did not amend the rule which I
think is a lot clearer than either the
house or the Senate
version and I that's different than what
you had proposed here yes yeah
it's yes this was my my attempt at
fixing the House and Senate versions but
that one's much nicer it it really gets
we would be agreeable with that okay
good and other than that
um that's all all the changes that we
would be requesting so essentially what
you want to do is use the language in
2272 except the final section you want
to replace it with this yes and and
delete section two and delete section
two because it's a duplicate oh yes with
the yeah not the final sentence of that
uh no you only need to mention the
duplicative remarks on all right then I
think
okay all
I we're going to the Senate version with
a with a second amendment with an
amendment yeah yes the other changes in
acceptable so Senate version with
Amendment and I wish they all went this
easy
well the the senate members had a bit of
a deadline so
we all right all right so you'll take
care again I will write the amendment
and write the report
perfect okay thank you very much
pleasure doing business we try have have
Manchester
e